[Music]
welcome to net 204 connecting your data
center to cloud approach for a
mission-critical network reliability my
name is Nick de Costa Faro I'm a
customer engineer here at Google
specializing in Google's dual cloud
network so first let's talk about
Google's network so when we talk about
Google's network we're talking about a
massive global platform as you can see a
hundred and thirty-four points of
presence massive investments in subsea
cabals connecting the world as you can
see behind me all within a private
backbone network that we own or that we
have private connectivity for the map
here clearly distinct some regions that
we have of course also future regions
that we're planning to launch as well as
the mast point of presence that we have
to connecting your data center to the
cloud so let's talk about about how do
you connect Google to the cloud so
connecting your place to our place we
actually have five ways of connecting
Google to the cloud we divide these into
two different sections public addressing
and private addressing the latter at the
top is the public addressing method
which is actually connecting Google via
the various means of peering so direct
peering is one of them which offers the
ability to connect to Google via
standard peering that you would do with
an internet exchange essentially
connecting your public prefixes so
public address blocks that you would own
to Google cloud via standard BGP peering
on the top right hand side we talked
about carrier peering carrier peering is
essentially the same means of connecting
to Google via public addressing however
through a carrier that provides that
connectivity so this is in case for
example you do not have the connectivity
to Google directly to be able to meet us
at our peering facilities you can do
that through a carrier on the bottom
part we speak about private addressing
now this is really interesting for
enterprise environments where you want
to extend connectivity from your
on-premise environment using private RFC
1918 addressing and connecting directly
to Google Cloud so that means being able
to reach directly your on-prem workloads
to Google Cloud
via two means of connectivity and then
of course we have the VPN option which
kind of sits hybrid in the middle which
provides a mix of connectivity across
public internet links to do the private
addressing extending your own prime
environment to the cloud so when you
speak of private addressing we actually
have two Metz's methods of doing this
once it's dedicated and our connect
which is to directly connect to Google
Cloud via one of our various points of
presence that means your equipment is
co-located in a point of presence or you
have connectivity to our point of
presence and establishing a dedicated
link to us the partner interconnect
offering is actually to provide
connectivity again privately however
through a partner a service provider
that is able to extend the last mile
connectivity from your on-premise
environment to Google cloud in case you
do not have connectivity in one of our
points of presence you could use a
partner interconnect to do that for you
and as a hybrid model as I mentioned VPN
is a way to connect via public internet
links and often enterprises start that
way before actually moving on to
purchase a dedicated or a partner
interconnect offering and I will show
you later on actually how seamlessly the
transition is done between a VPN
connectivity to Google cloud through a
partner dedicated interconnect link so
speak a bit about the cloud interconnect
but first I'm pleased to announce that
we are announcing 100 Gig connections on
our plops so now you're able to connect
not only with 10 gigs but now with 100
gig 100 gig connections at our points of
presence so cloud interconnect as I
mentioned is a method to provide access
to private RFC 1918 addressing from your
on-prem workloads directly to the cloud
and it enables essentially a hybrid
cloud connectivity model and does not
require the use of management of
hardware VPN devices because this is
something that you directly connect your
on-premise router to us via the various
pop locations that were located in so
from the left-hand side here we see
dedicated interconnect as I mentioned we
can do 10 gigs now we can do 100 gigs we
can provide an LACP bundle so a link
route bundle from 8 x 10 gigs or 2 x 100
gigs for provided transport circuits
directly to our cloud environment from
your own
promised data center and a partner
interconnect provides dedicated
bandwidth for subcircuit rates starting
at 50 megabits all the way to 10 gigs
provided through a service provider
network
so here's a bit about how the
interconnect deployment looks like so we
can look at a dedicated interconnect in
this MIT in this way we have a
colocation facility in the middle the
colocation facility is essentially where
you would meet us at one of our points
of presents so you may either have a
cage already established in one of the
facilities for example some of the
Equinix facilities is a very common
colocation facility or any other
colocation facilities or you can extend
connectivity there through through one
of any kind of telco providers that can
extend that connectivity to you and from
that you extend your on-premise
connection to your data center and we
provide connectivity to our cloud
network now here's a list of our
interconnect locations so as you can see
we're present all around the world in
all the continents except of course
Antarctica and then we have connectivity
with low latency links which is the dark
green circles which are providing very
little agency access to Google cloud
resources if you need a high highly low
latency access between your workloads
and Google cloud so that means you can
provide sub 5 milliseconds on average
from these sites to any regions that are
located in these points and presents
looking at the partner interconnect
offering this is essentially a model
where the partner is essentially
providing the connection to Google so
partners have established a partner
relationship with us already there
they've established connectivity with us
and they provide that last mile
connectivity to their clients so various
partners offer that and if you're not
looking for something at 10 gigs or
potentially higher throughput you would
look at our partner da for that because
they can provide subcircuit rates from
50 megabits all the way up to 10 gigs so
they can provide that solution and also
one thing that some partners are able to
offer as well is that they can minimize
the router requirements you may not need
a router at the colocation facility
themselves in case you want to do
something like a multi cloud scenario
and Wan connect cloud to cloud some
partners offer the ability to connect to
clouds together via virtual cloud
virtual router offering
so let's look at some of the distinction
between partner and dedicated
interconnect so why would you choose
partner why would you choose dedicated I
talk to a lot of customers depending on
their use case it's very clear partner
is where you're not able to have access
to our points of presence you're not
physically co-located in a point of
presence you may not need to have you
may not need to have a requirement of 10
gigs right you don't need 10 gigs which
is the minimum that we can offer with
dedicated interconnect therefore a
partner will provide you a subcircuit
rate starting from 50 megabits all the
way to 10 gigs and we can provide that
via v/line attachments on our end you
pay only for what you need
SLA is require at least I have two VLAN
attachments which would terminate at two
different availability zones within a
metro area if you want to have an SLA of
three 9s and then four nines you would
establish that across two different
metropolitan areas you can actually also
establish with partner interconnect you
don't need to be within one org we can
actually extend the connectivity from
multiple orgs because the partner
interconnect VLANs can land in different
organizational units within TCP for
dedicated it's often used by customers
that require high throughput they
require minimum of 10 gigs the customer
would essentially meet us at one of our
pops Oregon extend connectivity to one
of our pops either by a service provider
or meet us physically in one of our
point of presence all the VLANs
are actually writing on the same
physical link so that means that when
you establish VLAN attachments through
the through our cloud console you would
actually establish the VLAN attachments
within the same physical circuit that's
established with us SLA is again require
at least two connections to one of our
to one metro area across to availability
zones and then all VLANs need to land in
the same organizational unit and GCP for
dedicated interconnect that means that
you can establish a project in GCP
within within one org and that project
can share its resources but it's still
bound by the organization that's one of
the advantages that the partner
interconnect can do is you can actually
spend that across multiple organization
if you need to
so let's talk about a few different ways
that you can actually use interconnect
on some of the use cases that our
customers are using today so here's just
an example again of the private routing
that you can establish between
on-premise and your between your
on-premise infrastructure and our cloud
environment so essentially would
establish a BGP peer via our our
offering which is called a cloud router
which would be deployed in the cloud
region and an established BGP peering
with your on-premise router and
exchanging prefixes in this case here we
have a headquarter with an external data
center that has a some you know network
of 192 168 50 5.0 / 24 and we're
advertising that to the cloud region and
the cloud regions receiving that prefix
/ BGP in a cloud region has 192 168 49.0
/ 24 and we're advertising that across
so we can establish that connectivity
through through the cloud router which
is our virtual BGP speaker in the cloud
and your on-premise BGP speaker another
use case that we've seen is because of
the concept of global routing and the
concept of our global network we're
essentially able to deploy within one
VPC multiple regions so that actually
allows you to connect with one router
that you deploy in one region other you
can actually reach natively other
regions within GCP so that means that
we're able to advertise prefixes that
would exist let's say in a different
region then the region where the cloud
router is deployed and you can actually
ride the backbone of Google's network to
provide connectivity between these
regions you do not need to duplicate
your effort and building separate cloud
router instances in different regions
this is done natively through our global
backbone network it's a flag that's
enabled in cloud router when you
actually deploy this it's called global
routing it labels you to seamlessly
transition our network and allow access
to remote regions from the cloud routers
region
DNS is another one of our very popular
solutions as well customers would like
to deploy on premise they have on
premise already a DNS server where they
have post names that they're resolving
for their private you know private
resources on on-prem and then they also
want to deploy resources in the cloud so
they would use cloud DNS in the cloud
specify specific a records for different
VMs that they spin up within the cloud
and they wouldn't want their on-premise
environment to also resolve hostnames in
the cloud so they would do that via DNS
forwarding we have both inbound and
outbound DNS forwarding which actually
allows you to resolve hostnames from
on-premise workloads to the cloud and
also from the cloud to on premise
workloads and we can allow that through
the means of interconnect so by either a
dedicated or partner interconnect or
through VPN we're able to extend that
connectivity via the means of DNS
forwarding another great offering is
through the shared VPC model so within
Google Cloud we're able to deploy a
model via shared VPC which essentially
structures a host project which is
essentially the anchor for all your
networking resources within the cloud so
service projects do not need to worry
about networking they just need to
consume resources they can be
development teams that just want to
deploy applications they don't need to
know about the underlying networking
infrastructure the routing the subnets
the firewall policies this is all done
by a centralized networking project that
would be managed by generally a
networking team within your organization
and that project would deploy cloud
router within a region and in that cloud
router could essentially share the
resources of the interconnect with the
individual service project so the
service project would consume networking
resources similar to subnets that you
would grant them access to and they can
natively route with any routing that's
available within the host project to
your on-premise environment so again
it's really simplifies the model you
don't need to duplicate multiple
interconnections in each project you can
actually centralize this have a central
network administration team that manages
the networking for your environment and
the rest of the the teams that need to
manage development projects or other
types of service projects do not need to
worry about networking and they're
essentially connected back to your
on-premise environment via policies that
you set
another use case is connecting privately
to Google services Google as many api is
that you expose for example cloud
storage or bigquery that you would may
want to utilize from on-premise and also
because you have a dedicated link to
Google it's a good benefit to be able to
use that link with low latency access
high throughput to be able to store data
to Alexis a cloud storage bucket or to
load data into bigquery services so it
can actually advertise by a single by a
VIP range back to your on-premise
environment at that API that you can
call and then you can actually make
calls to Google Cloud API services that
are available through this API so this
supports Google API endpoints there's a
subset of endpoints that's currently
supported with us and essentially
on-premise what you would do is you do a
DNS change to rewrite the Google API
domain to use a specific VIP of VIP
range that allows you to connect to
these to these prefixes through an
interconnect link and you would
advertise that prefix which is you can
see in this example here it's 199 36 153
4/30 on the cloud router back to your
on-premise environment so the cloud
router actually allows you to program
which routes you would want to advertise
and by advertising this range making the
necessary DNS changes you can actually
connect back to on-prem to Google API
services natively
let's talk a bit about high L high
availability topologies so one circuit
as I mentioned earlier does not give you
any kind of SL A's to have an SL you
need to have two circuits for redundancy
so in this case we have a colocation
facility which is located in one
metropolitan area that metropolitan area
would have two availability zones so to
have any kind of SLA a39 SLA with us you
would need to connect across two of
these metropolitan availability zones in
a single metro so with BGP graceful
restart and cloud router we're able to
provide means of having a high
availability across these two zones now
for customers that require very high
availability we would want to duplicate
that effort across two metropolitan
areas so in this case you may have
Metropolitan Area on the East Coast
maybe one on the west coast and you
would be again connected across two
availability zones within these
metropolitan areas and that would
provide you a 4/9 SLA with us to connect
back to GCP and within GCP you would
deploy a cloud router in one region and
a cloud router in the other region
generally as close as possible to where
you are co-located geographically so if
it's on the west coast you would pick a
region on the west coast and on the East
Coast you would pick a region on the
east coast with the means of global
routing as I mentioned earlier we're
actually able to natively transit our
network in case of failure so if we were
to lose an entire region we're able a
route via the other region to connect
back to your on-premise environment via
this this model of deployment
and now I'd like to introduce my
colleague Sasha on stage to talk about a
high availability cloud VPN
hi I'm Sasha and one of the engineers at
a European team and if there is one
thing I learned in my years working for
with en it is that reliability is a
critical feature of VPN because if your
connectivity from your on-prem location
to DCP is down you'll feel it across all
organization now the protocol that we
use to run VPN is the Enderson standard
called IPSec it's pretty good when you
consider its encryption capabilities but
its ability to detect and route around
failures is not so good so if anything
fails on the way from TCP to your
location then your tunnel will be toast
and and we want to build a more reliable
connection and to do that the way is to
use redundancy so you can set up several
tunnels running in parallel between the
two location and hoping that if one is
down the other will still there so that
gives you some value but that's not
enough because if those tunnels share
any component on the way from GCP to
your location if there is a fault in
that component again your whole
connection will be down so not only you
need to provide a redundant connection
you need to be able to isolate failure
by making sure that no at no stage there
is a single point of failure in which
your tunnels is working now as being
cloud
this is virtualized Hardware so where to
even start so to do that we developed a
new VPN product called high variability
VPN and for that we have a new kind of
cloud VPN gateway slightly different
from the old one and what it does it
provides you with two interfaces
and you can think of them as two
different metal cards similarly to to
the physical network arts you would put
in your computer so if one of them is
burned out the others are still
continuing to run your traffic but this
is virtual so if you have two tunnels
attached to two of the interfaces we
will make sure that they are nothing
they share no line cards no network
connections no machines no switches
actually being cloud we are pretty sure
that they will not even share data
center so they are pretty much separated
and if one of them goes down the other
is still assured and very likely to be
working and then if this further of
scenario happens then a short time after
that the system will discover and that
one tunnel went unhealthy and switch all
the traffic over to the healthy tunnel
now how much exactly that gives you in
terms of reliability it's a good
question it's a function of how good is
the isolation and how fast is the
process of switching over from unhealthy
tunnel to the healthy one and we did
this analysis for our system and I'm
happy to announce that we are going to
provide four nines which is nine nine
point ninety nine regional availability
so it means four and a half minutes of
maximum monthly downtime or 53 minutes
yearly and just a few notes so this is a
regional product you do not need to go
multi-regional to have this level of
availability just one region is enough
you will be able to connect just as with
classical pain that we had you'll be
able to connect both DCP to DCP or to
your own pram locations or even to
another cloud the only requirement that
is mandatory now and was optional with
classic with pian is that we need the
VPN on the other side to support dynamic
routing if you think of it it makes
total sense because you want your system
to be able
to failover to switch the traffic from
one path to another so it's natural and
one last thing to notice is that when
you're providing this redundant
connection you are actually having twice
as many tunnels as you're sure to have
in case there is any system failure
so if you watch the observable capacity
that you have in your bandwidth then it
will be twice as much as you will have
assured and so if there is any failure
then your available bandwidth will will
go down by a factor of two and that's
not the time when you want to discover
that you actually needed more tunnels
than you have configured so to have a
consistent experience of your bandwidth
staying constant all the time what we
recommend is to set up a VPN connection
in an active/passive configuration
meaning that one of the tunnels has
priority and all the traffic flows to it
until that unless that fails and all the
traffic switches over to the other
tunnel with dynamic routing again that's
easy to set up you just use different
medval use and that's it so to recap we
have we're going to provide four lines
availability this system is currently in
alpha it's going to launch together next
month and yeah here is the more traffic
running more smoothly Nick back to you
thank you
thank you thank you
okay so putting all that into
perspective now I will actually go
through a demo that looks at a common
enterprise use case where we have an
enterprise that starts with a VPN tunnel
here for example I have a customer
project I have an IPSec tunnel connected
back to a customer router on Prem I set
as sasha was talking about the med
values which are important in terms of
traffic engineering that we're doing
within the interconnect model so in this
case I have a standard med med value of
a hundred and then I would like to set
up another connection this other
connection would be a dedicated or
partner interconnect offering and and I
don't want traffic to switch over to
this connection so I create a connection
create it with a lower med value of 1000
and I establish a link now once that
link is established traffic will not
seamlessly switch over yet because the
value of the med priorities are
preferred over the VPN tunnel then from
the interconnect connection now to do a
traffic switch over it's very simple we
just switch the med values between the
VPN connection and the inter connect
connection by swapping them and then the
traffic seamlessly moves over so now I
have a VPN connection that could be used
as a backup I can keep it online case I
needed but right now my traffic would
actually be routed across a dedicated or
connector partner interconnect link
so here's a topology of what we're doing
for this demo so I actually have a hav
p.m. so deployed with two interfaces
they're both deployed and active passive
right now with med value of 100 med
value of 200 so active passive on the
VPN link and then I have my interconnect
links which with higher med values 1000
and 1200 and they're connected back to
an on-premise environment which I'm
running a ping test between that and a
VM within GCP so you can see here I have
this in my cloud console with this
project I just showed the topology so we
have here the interconnect session and
the VPN sessions you can see here the
one thousand and a twelve hundred as
advertised route priority and we can see
here the 100 and 200 for my VPN
connections my VPN tunnels so here I'm
running a ping test between the VM on
Prem and in a VM sorry on Prem workload
and in a VM and GCP as you can see here
we have kind of sporadic pings between
20 to 30 millisecond this is running
across the internet this is a VPN tunnel
it's not predictable do the path nature
of the internet so I can't really rely
on some hearing team chose milliseconds
it's pretty sporadic it's flipping up
and down I want to now switch traffic
over to a dedicated interconnect link to
have higher throughput and also lower
latency so here I'm just running a
script which is actually going to set
the priorities swap them between the
interconnect and the VPN tunnels and
once the it's really what I'm doing is
I'm switching the priorities both on the
VPN side in GCP both VPN and err connect
side on GCP and also on Prem from my own
Prem router to make sure that we're
updating on both sides so that it's
symmetrical traffic of course it's
important to do that so that traffic
runs both symmetrically between the
peers and once that's actually completed
then we should see that traffic the
latency is going to be reduced quite
significantly because we're gonna go
through across the dedicated
interconnect link with much lower with
much lower latency and higher throughput
and as you can see now we've actually
lowered it down once it stabilizes
should be around eight nine minutes
milliseconds when traffic is running
across the interconnect as you can see
now it's around nine milliseconds a lot
of traffic seamlessly moved over
to the interconnect link instead of the
VPN tunnel
and as you can see I've seamlessly
transitioned traffic there's no packet
loss easy to do now you can move traffic
over and you have traffic writing across
the the interconnect link and if we look
at the cloud console and refresh it
now we see that the priorities have been
swapped so the inter connect session now
has 100 and 200 that's the preferred
path active passive path across the
interconnect and 1000 1200 for the VPN
tunnels so they're still there in case
we need it as a backup in case there
would be a failure
we can still transition traffic across
the interconnect so it's that simple to
be able to do a migration between VPN
and interconnect seamlessly between your
enterprise and GCP and with that that is
the end of my demo I'd like to introduce
Steve Olsen from the Home Depot and talk
about his a interconnect experience
thank you
[Applause]
hey my name is Steve but everyone calls
me Steve oh you'll have to excuse me
my voice is a little bit under the
weather today caught something here but
we will push forward I've been with the
Home Depot for 12 13 years which means
I'm incredibly tired and I've seen lots
of different things we like to say we've
seen a lot of changes and Home Depot in
the last five years probably more than
we've seen in the past 10 or 15 and that
really goes to speak to our digital
transformation things that we've done
we've really put IT first it wasn't
always the case when I first started IT
was kind of a vaccine now I t's kind of
a front seat driver and we've really
done the strategy called interconnected
retail it's really an omni-channel
strategy that lets our customers buy
online pick up in store buy online ship
to their home buy in the store all that
kind of merges together to give the
customer the choice and one of that big
strategies that we played first with
first was the cloud GCP we chose to do
econ 4 and we have a journey that come
and used the tools and the guys have
been talking about and how we connected
to GCP but first I'm going to start with
some base facts about Home Depot I won't
read everything on this slide but Home
Depot is found in 1978 last year we did
a hundred billion hundred eight billion
dollars in sales
dot-com was up 22% linking sales and
there's some calm guys here but in front
I think in the last five years six years
we've actually increased comm sales by a
billion dollars almost every single year
a lot of that growth has been in our
cloud space we completely replac form
calm and we'll talk about that in just a
second we've over 150 supply chain
facilities we have over 2,000 stores
spread out across Canada u.s. and Mexico
and of course 400,000 associates what a
lot of people don't realize is we do
have a big IT presence we have over
3,000 IT associates we hired just under
a thousand last year and we're still go
we have offices all across the country
from our various brands that define home
the phone companies that we use and with
that I'll start with our actual strategy
and how we started with the cloud so
what kind of led up to a distributed
model for us is really just starting
with e-commerce first in around 2014
we'd completely replac formed the
website it was decided that we would go
from an on-prem model to in the cloud
and some of the reasons are the classic
reasons that you would hear but we were
building our own premise infrastructure
for sales that wouldn't be around
Thanksgiving or Black Friday or Father's
Day and you build this infrastructure to
the point where you're using it for
those days only and then the rest of the
year it's it's stagnant so we really
wanted a more on-demand infrastructure
that could scale and of course the cloud
came into the hat with multiple years to
do really this is gonna be a condensed
timeline but I'll explain exactly how we
got there
one of the first things is data movement
but how do we actually get data from our
own friend to the GCP cloud and the
first thing of course is before we even
get going with lots of projects it's
just a basic internet and so we have
basic proxies and internet and that
doesn't scale incredibly well what if
you need private services just like they
talked about and the slides before maybe
pm's interconnects we first started
using VPNs and I've kind of got a
love-hate really read relationship with
VPNs some people like them
I hate VPNs and I'll explain that for a
few reasons
I mean VPNs suck let's face it but if
that's all you can do that's all you can
do right we actually do static routes
there was no cloud router at this point
this is around 2015 so we were stuck
with static routes and no redundancy and
it worked
it accepted terminated on-prem here and
then it terminated it inside the cloud
you know it basically did what it needed
to do but we needed something more
robust and we needed to scale high and
so
the promise with VPN which I said we'll
talk about MTU how many of you have ever
ever dealt with frame size issues and
MTU problems with VPNs like everyone's
hands gonna but MTU is a terrible thing
to deal with in it's not Google's fault
but Google you have to have
fragmentation before encapsulation and
if you are dealt with firewalls and and
packet captures and wire captors for why
something doesn't work does your
application even support fragmentation
doesn't know it's gonna be fragmented I
I just need an Advil just talking about
it we dealt with that so long that we
needed to get rid of that speed and
latency is another big thing one of the
big things that I found about speed
Alain sees that if you talk to your
customers sometimes they don't know what
the difference between that is they
might say I need something quick but
it's quick mean I need a load a terabyte
of data in a day or I need a connection
to a database in five milliseconds
sometimes you have to actually leave
that conversation there to see exactly
what they care about all right SOA and
the Internet in general that's a big
thing as well you'd come in one day and
your connection across the Internet's 30
milliseconds in the next day it's 45
we've all dealt with that we actually
made a diagram that basically show cold
potato hot potato routing to explain to
our application developers and our
consumers what it's like that yes we
have internet connections to the cloud
but we don't go straight there I don't
own the infrastructure in the middle and
getting their heads wrapped around the
fact that yes I may leave here but I
don't know what some tier one provider
does with it after the fact and that's
how we explain that to them so let's see
what the VPN issue first right so what
we really wanted to have a way to have
the VPN be better we couldn't fix the
MTU immediately but we could fix them in
the speed and latency problems so this
is where we really started discussing
peering facilities so we actually came
up with if we could get the VPNs closer
to Google we can actually get
performance better so speed latency
reliability SLA and so we came up with
peering centers on the east and on the
west coast those are the first good
choices because a lot of the
infrastructure
four things that were using are there we
have well-defined lanes use now so
instead of using the Internet we own
these private circuits between some of
our daters directly to these pairing
centers so I can tell my application
developers and all my teams I know what
you're going to get from a late from a
latency perspective I know this it's 15
I know this is 40 and we don't have to
worry about the internet so what we
really did is revisiting the first slide
as we moved the VPN connections all the
way out to the Colo there in the pairing
centers and the VPN still inside the
project so the Internet's not used right
but reliability and that's the way go
way up speed is now actually even better
because now we have direct connections
so we're running the VPN basically on
the last mile we're not running it
across the country and hoping that it
gets there we have our own private
circuits that gets us there all right so
the real redundancy actually still isn't
here yet so we actually started doing
multiple VPNs but without cloud router
and static routes and trying to scale
that that's yeah that didn't work either
so we needed to do something even better
than that all right it actually worked
well enough that we basically started
adding more people liked it so much that
we added a couple more so now we have
seven milliseconds and three we actually
have vendors and application owners that
test this and can get connections
straight to GCP within 10 milliseconds
all right so once we started doing that
thought well interconnect beta started
and if we can get the interconnect on we
can get rid of the VPNs right so now
we're gonna fix the VPN issue that's
still problem with the MTU so what
happens is the interconnect beta comes
cloud router comes and we have now an
interconnect plus a direct connect so at
each of the peering facilities we have
four different cables we have two for
public access to Frick interconnect and
depending on what the project needs are
they can do private access or they can
be public access over our own
infrastructure to get there the
Internet's not involved and of course
with dynamic routing the redundancy is
much more seamless and it fails
much easier so with that we basically
grew even more we actually added in
another facility this year and all these
sites back each other out they're
talking about mission-critical
reliability you build this in such a way
that when we have circuit issues and
some of these go down our application
orders don't even notice because if
they're multi region and multi attached
to different interconnects and use pile
routers and automatically fails over all
right so that's we just feel - they're
now but we're even adding more and
really it's not just UCP either the
journey to exit getting is connected
directly to gz p led us to other things
we're using it for other providers as
well and other vendors and partners of
us and even the internet itself so just
the concept of getting to GCP led us to
this distributed regionalised network
that we can use and with the combination
of you know new technologies like Sdn
and things like that
we can have our remote sites our stores
our distribution centers we could have
them all come to the closest peering
facility and use cloud services or use
the internet and things that that that
they might need they don't need to come
back to the main offices they don't need
to go directly to the air and we can
control that all in a centralized
regionalised manner and so with that
being said what we're doing next is
we're investigating what we exeed they
talked about in the last few slides it
is private services via these channels
meaning using our private space to
contact a query and things like that
we're really interested in shared VPC
and we're going to continue deploying
more pairing centers and keep using the
multi region model and quad routers and
interconnects and we'll probably even
expand to more appearing centers in
Canada and Mexico this year
this model has proved extremely well our
customers like it and we will continue
to do that with that being said
[Music]
you